de temps en temps cela vous ennuie
l'at-il de man mais loin de tout ça
juste pour aller voir la mer juste pour
qu'elle nous laisse les pieds juste
faire semblant d'oublier sentir chaque
grain de sable effleuré paumé plantes
sentir chaque algues caresser nos
chevilles sentir dans nos cheveux tout
le ciel qui vante de temps en temps cela
vous en irait-il de me surprendre au
coin d'une rue oublier que je voulais
demander admettons que soient étonnés
agréablement surprise qu après un
sursaut je vous sautent au cou etc après
avoir plongé mon regard dans le vôtre
avec l'indiscrétion d'y trouver quelque
chose je vous vole un baiser pour le
mettre dans ma poche et le garder pour
quand vous ne serez plus là et je me
sentirai seul avec tout ce monde autour
alors je le prendrais tout doucement en
creux de ma main et le poserait
lentement sur ma joue la voyait santé
comme seydou santé de temps en temps
cela vous en irait-il de me porter sur
votre dos rêvant de m'isoler facilement
loin du sol là où tout est si beau comme
les notes de vote d'eau comme les aurons
de votre don mello 10 de mes sens vous
voyez comme j'y pense et mes pieds sont
si lourds est mais vert sont si court
mais si msila mme roy et me labour je
laisse sur le trottoir des traces de pas
en créer non
un qu'une fois pourriez vous me portez
de temps en temps cela vous ennuierait
t-il de me laisser vous caresser du bout
de ma plume du bout de mes edouard jeu
redessinerait vote visage comme on
esquisse un paysage le ferait un jour de
brume pour cacher un peu mais c'est moi
et mes et moi mais je mets jeu rien que
pour vous rien que pour nous deux vous
savez il en faut aussi peu j'aurais
juste une dernière requête
je vous garde encore un peu je voulais
juste vous demander si de temps en temps
cela vous en irait-il que je vous
tutoient pour dire toi et moi comme au
ciné pour dire nous c'est tous pour dire
tu me transporte pour dire tu me chavire
pour dire tu mens nive pour dire tu
m'inspires pour dire et redire des tu à
tue tête car au creux de ma tête c'est
toi qui déborde pour dire tes baisers me
brûle me transporte pour dire tu me
plais bien plus encore oui de temps en
temps cela sans nuire est il de
m'emmener loin de tout ça juste pour
aller voir la mer juste pour qu'elle
nous laisse les piéger faire semblant
d'oublier cas de vous à moi
celui que je préfère c'est toi c'est
avec ce texte que j'avais gagné le
championnat de france de slam en 2005
et oui moi
vous n'imaginez pas un champion de sam
comme ça
le slam qu'est ce que c'est une scène
ouverte où chaque personne du public
peut venir s'exprimer
on te donne trois minutes tu peux en
faire ce que tu veux sans accessoire
sans musique sans décor juste le texte
la voix le corps un terrain d'expression
libre ou rappeur poète conteur chanteur
simplement amoureux des mots peuvent se
rencontrer échanger
finalement c'est assez proche de ce
qu'on fait ici aujourd'hui
bien que tedx ne soit pas une scène slam
et l'on vous ne pourrez pas monter sur
scène après moi désolé
à part peut-être ceux qui attendent leur
tour
caché derrière j'ai toujours été attiré
par la scène
depuis tout petit je chantais sans arrêt
et imaginer des superproductions en
costume pour mes parents je pensais
juste quand vivre ça n'arrive qu'aux
autres
c'est un rêve d'enfant aujourd'hui je
suis auteur compositeur interprète c'est
mon métier
la découverte du slam à l'âge de 17 ans
a été un élément déclencheur c'est là
que j'ai pris conscience que mon envie
de monter sur scène était bien réelle
que j'ai réalisé aussi que je voulais
écrire pour être entendu tout à coup
tout est devenu possible
et quant à 20 ans j'ai tout quitté pour
faire un disque j'avais pas peur du tout
c'était une évidence aujourd'hui
j'appelle ce moment l'été le plus
spontané de ma vie j'ai sorti un premier
album en 2009 puis un second en 2015
entre les deux le monde de la musique a
beaucoup changé
ce deuxième album une gelée autoproduit
les chansons étaient prêtes et je ne
voulais plus attendre d'une maison
disque se décide à me produire
je me suis retrouvé chef d'entreprise
bateau dans ce contexte en mouvement en
transition j'ai dû apprendre un nouveau
métier
plusieurs même celui de productrice de
directrice marketing de chargé de
projets de community manager prise dans
une tornade de mails de logistique un
tourbillon d'objectifs et de code
obligatoire qu'elle se plier quand on
veut faire un disque un peu j'ai perdu
pied
oubliant cachés sous ses multiples
casquettes que j'étais artiste avant
tout au tout dans les pensées en a l'air
tout autour tance les pensées en haleine
tout je les femmes honte et je les fais
mon temps je les fais monter temps je
les femmes honte et je les fait remonter
le temps j'ai fait mon temps mon bateau
de papier et je les laisse
fogué
on dit ce qui est sorti j'ai pu trouver
des aides des partenaires pour ma
compagnie j'ai reçu tout un tas de
retour élogieux mais quelque chose
clochait je ressentais de la déception
la frustration et même de la culpabilité
j'avais l'impression d'avoir échoué
quelque part alors qu'à mon échelle
c'était plutôt le contraire
comment j'en suis arrivée là je me suis
comparer jeu mettait constamment mon
projet en parallèle de ceux des autres
j'avais l'impression qu'ils y arrivent à
mieux que moi trompé par toutes ces
images de succès qu'on peut voir sur les
réseaux sociaux et internet
d'ailleurs beaucoup ont dû penser la
même chose en visitant ma page facebook
toujours plein de bonnes nouvelles on
nous met en avant que le positif on ne
parle presque jamais de nos épreuves et
du coup on se retrouve avec cette
impression d'être le seul à rencontrer
des difficultés alors que c'est faux
nous en rencontrons tous on gagnerait
peut-être à en parler plus souvent non
moi j'en ai jamais assez même si je
travaillais du matin au soir presque 7
jours sur 7
je passais mon temps au téléphone ou sur
mon ordinateur je prenais plus le temps
d'écrire pour moi capitaine ça a été une
terrible tempête intérieure et des
trombes d'eau j'étais je suis si fier de
cet album
j'en ai mais chaque parcelle et malgré
ça je voyais mon verre à moitié vide
je me concentrais sur le reste à remplir
plutôt que sur le chemin accompli
je me levais le matin avec avec cette
question qui tournaient en boucle
à quoi bon
il était temps de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
tenter d'y répondre à un moment je n'ai
juste plus réussi à savourer mes succès
alors qu'il était là sous mes yeux
bref enfant j'ai sorti de disque de
gagner des prix
je chantais dans de grands festivals
dans des salles magnifiques comme
l'olympia j'ai participé à plein de gros
projets et surtout surtout je vide mon
arme et quelle chance
ça devrait être le comble du bonheur
pourtant à un moment j'ai oublié qui
j'étais et pourquoi je faisais tout cela
est l'importance est s'en rendre compte
non c'est normal de douter c'est pas une
route en ligne droite c'est mouvementée
c'est une traversée
aujourd'hui je veux regarder mon verre
le voir à moitié plein et aimer cette
moitié l'a trouvée elle je veux
continuer d'écrire cultiver ma
singularité arrêté de me comparer parce
que c'est ça qui me paralyse et surtout
je veux plus perdre de vue cette raison
si fondamental qui répond à tous mais à
quoi bon parce que j'aime ce que je fais
par dessus tout parce que j'adore
chercher les mots justes écoutez comment
ils sonnent parce que j'aime les
partager sur scène avec avec ma voix
avec avec mes mains avec mon visage et
mes pieds nus parce que pour moi c'est
une nécessité que je me verrais pas
faire autre chose de ma vie
voilà pourquoi je fais de la musique
enfin pour atteindre cette vision du
succès que le monde voudrait nous
imposer
j'ai déjà réussi et c'est la cerise sur
le gâteau si dans mes mots quelques-uns
viennent d'assez reconnaître quand
le silence sur ce fait assourdissant que
des sons minuscule fonck d'âge et en nos
sondés compas nos guides sur l'océan
comme continent il nous reste ça quand
les nuages film sans qu'on puisse les
toucher dans le bleu tendre il
impossible d'accoster nos mousson des
trois mâts navigue danser nue et non
moins qu'en me voilier il nous restera
ça et quand le ciel pleure ce grise de
sanglots que les sons les couleurs se
prennent dans les halls onomo à bout de
bras ce sont nos armes aux flambeaux
comme drapeau
il nous restera ça qu'on les portes sont
fermées que l'on reste dehors quand on a
beau frapper de nos mains de nos corps
les mots restent on l'a gravé dans le
décor nos mots comme trésor il nous
restera ça quand mes lèvres sont scellés
je ne sais que dire quand je ne sais que
pleurer quand je voudrai sourire mes
mots glissent eux tout bas pour éviter
le pire mais mort comme des soupirs
qu'il reste ça quand on voudrait fixer
chaque souvenir chaque nom pour ne rien
oublier de chaque sensation les mots
sont nos combats les mots sont les
motions nos mots comme chanson il nous
restera ça
merci
voilà je ne gardais que ça ce goût de la
scène ce besoin de transmettre par la
voix de partager des textes qui inspire
c'est un peu ce qu'on fait tous ensemble
ici cet après midi voilà ce qui est
important pour moi et je suis certaine
que vous aussi vous connaissez la
réponse à votre à quoi bon cette idée
plus forte que tout qui sera toujours là
pour nous guider quand nous nous
sentirons égard est la mienne l'évidence
de mes 20 ans mon rêve de petite fille
je ne veux plus l'oublier nie toutes ces
victoires qui n'appartiennent qu'à moi
et à mon chemin plein de virages temps
qu'elle resteront là je pourrais
continuer malgré les doutes et les
obstacles la mer agitée la persévérance
et la passion pour aller y est alors le
vent nous verre à moitié plein et
réjouissons-nous qu'il reste tant de
place pour les remplir encore à nous